i'm excited about this because i love
hearing about all the new ways people
are using their hobbies and passion for
a good cause
and dory kaplan is doing just that she's
a college sophomore
from new jersey who's using her free
time to make jewelry
and sell it to raise money for feeding
america dory's with us now hi
dory oh
and you're so cute and pretty and a
do-gooder and just the whole complete
package
i'll probably go back and study this
football play and be like oh great
you're just a creepy stalker
but you really are just such a good
person beautiful on the inside
and out how did you become interested in
making jewelry dory
so i started making jewelry when i was
in fourth or fifth grade after i went to
a summer camp at a local beach shop in
my town
and after that i just fell in love with
making jewelry i think for my birthday i
asked for all of the jewelry making
supplies
um and then from there i actually did my
first charity project for jewelry when i
was in sixth grade
for my bat mitzvah project and then i
kept making jewelry throughout the years
both for myself and as gifts for friends
and family and then recently
with the pandemic i started raising
money for feeding america by selling it
okay first i want you to come and teach
my daughter olive what kind of person to
be
and frankie because gosh i could only
hope that they would be
so thoughtful as you and we wanted to
share your story with
one of our friends um i have such deep
respect for this woman renowned jewelry
designer kendra scott
is one of the most successful female
entrepreneurs with a
billion valuation and a hundred stores
around the country
oh and new gig she's also a recurring
shark
now on shark tank please welcome
kendra scott
are you true dory
so great to see you both kendra i have
to tell you
you have been you are such a huge
supporter
of females in business and ever since i
started flower we've had
this lovely dialogue going back and
forth about
how you know we can support each other
and you just have been
such an amazing force in my life and
someone
that i i just appreciate so much and can
you
quickly tell me about when you first
started making jewelry yourself kendra
yeah so i started out of the extra
bedroom of my house
19 years ago if you can believe it uh
and i literally made everything by hand
just like you
dory uh and took my jewelry door to door
here in austin texas
is how i got started and it literally 19
years of building this business
have now gotten to to it where it is
today but
from day one i decided i wanted to do
what i loved which was jewelry design i
was a new mom
so i wanted to create a company that
loved and supported new mothers and
fathers
and i wanted to give back and so i never
said no to any non-profit that would
call me i'd always have something to
give
and seeing dory and hearing her story
what an inspiration and you remind me so
much of myself in in those early days
and
and so inspired by you i love that and
when i was doing
the research i was like oh my gosh
there's some symmetry here
in the origin story and kendra you just
lift women up so
much and by the way i'm wearing each one
of your bracelets the beautiful dory
bracelet right here
and the beautiful kendra bracelet and we
have all of dory's stuff and kendra you
have a surprise for dory
i do well first of all i am again
i just love what you're doing and so i
named a piece of jewelry after you dory
and it is look at this gorgeous beauty
that is droozy
that is one of my favorite stones and it
sparkles it's
inside of a geode right it's so
delicious and this is now the dory
necklace the cool thing
also about this is we want to support
you and your cause for feeding america
and so we are donating 5 000
in your name to feeding america and
this little necklace 20
of every single necklace sold online and
in store is going to go back to feeding
america starting today
through the end of december
[Music]
thank you kendra thank you dory by the
way i'll put that on my little yellow
book list
the dory necklace this week kendra i had
two pieces of yours
on last week's list i'm such a fan of
both of yours thank you both so much for
coming on the show
and showing what is possible for women
in business
not only to do and accomplish in this
world
but the give back the philanthropy the
amazing intention behind
everything you guys do thank you
[Music]
you